[Musik]
und jetzt das heute journal mit hanna
zimmermann und christian sievers
guten abend in allen am ende einer woche
die die westliche welt ganz
grundsätzlich erschüttert hat blankes
entsetzen war da zu spüren den
hauptstädten europas seltene
selbstkritik bei den handelnden
politikern und dann die suche nach einer
passenden antwort nicht einfach denn wie
russlands präsident die menschen in der
ukraine an greift das hat es seit dem
ende des zweiten weltkriegs in europa
nicht mehr gegeben jetzt tut sich
einiges auch und gerade in berlin und
damit beginnen wir heute abend auf zwei
wichtigen feldern bewegt sich die
bundesregierung
und theo koll ist für uns in berlin theo
guten abend beginnen wir vielleicht mal
mit den waffenlieferungen sehr wichtig
ist auch sehr umstrittenes thema
waffenlieferungen an die ukraine bislang
waren die ausgeschlossen auch aus
ehemaligen deutschen beständen die in
drittstaaten liegen und jetzt
ja und jetzt ist auch die
bundesregierung in einer anderen welt
angekommen selbst der kanzler hat heute
das wort von der zeitenwende benutzt die
alte politische position keine waffen in
die ukraine zu liefern die ist
vergangenheit und hatte die
bundesregierung allzu erkennbar auch ins
internationale aus befördert die
weigerung estland die lieferung alte
haubitzen aus ddr beständen zu
genehmigen die war ja schon erkennbar
eine unangemessene haltung in dieser
ganzen frage heute hat man dann in
berlin gleich mehrfach und ziemlich
rasant die kurve gekriegt ist begann mit
der freigabe der estnischen hauben und
von panzerfäusten aus dem bestand der
niederlande dann am abend kamen die
amtliche bestätigung dass jetzt auch die
bundeswehr direkt und aus eigenen
beständen an die ukraine liefert und
2000 panzerabwehrwaffen und 500 boden
luft raketen vom typ sting also wenn man
im bild bleiben will dann hat der
russische angriff jetzt auch einige
vertraute fundamente deutscher
sicherheitspolitik zerschossen und dann
gucken wir auf die finanzielle seite
swift ist in aller munde also das
zahlungssystem dass die internationale
wirtschaft verbindet und am laufen hält
deutschland war bisher zurückhaltend
russland davon auszuschließen aber auch
das ändert sich jetzt ja denn auch da
war die bundesregierung am ende in einer
sehr unbequemen position und quasi
allein zu haus noch und freitag gab es
ja eine ganze reihe europäischer staaten
die sich ebenfalls gegen dieses
sogenannte schärfste sanktion schwert
ausgesprochen hatten aber einer nach dem
anderen sprang dann ab und am ende stand
deutschland alleine da es soll heute
abend eine konferenzschaltung geben
unter anderem mit den usa frankreich
italien und offensichtlich will man sich
auf eine art abgespeckte swift
sanktionen verständigen das heißt einige
große russische banken sollen sehr
gezielt aus dem swift gestrichen werden
aber eben nicht alle russischen banken
und da war wird spannend sein zu sehen
was das in der folge für die deutschen
energieimporte bedeutet denn wenn bei
einer swift sanktion die deutschen
energie einkäufe in russland nicht mehr
bezahlt werden können dann folgt daraus
auch das risiko dass die lieferungen
eingestellt wird genau das wollte die
bundesregierung vermeiden aber der druck
und der politische flurschaden waren
offensichtlich zu hoch also seitenwände
allerorten thema mit vielen potenziellen
folgen theo herzlichen dank für diese
information heute abend und
währenddessen treffen die raketen
russischer truppen wohnhäuser in der
ukraine die aussehen wie die in denen
sie selbst aufgewachsen sind sie fahren
mit ihren panzern über straßen im
nachbarland die wirken wie bei sich zu
hause sie sehen menschen die ihre eigene
familie sein könnten vielleicht ist all
das teil der erklärung dafür dass sich
berichte häufen der krieg laufe nicht
nach putins plan vielleicht ist es aber
auch nur wunschdenken aus westlicher
sicht in der hoffnung auf ein schnelles
ende
wir werden darüber noch ausführlich
sprechen heute abend gleich auch live
mit kiew aber erst fasst christian von
rechenberg die aktuelle lage zusammen
herr iwanow ist gerettet am ende seiner
kraft aber in sicherheit die stärkung
tut ihm gut eine unterkunft will der
helfer auch gleich den finden ivanov
lebt in charkiw im osten der ukraine um
vier uhr in der früh kam die raketen
ich habe gleich alles in eine tasche
gepackt was ich konnte auch meine
dokumente und ging zum bahnhof
am bahnhof waren jede menge menschen die
reise war schwer ich habe ungefähr zwei
tage bis hiernach muss corot gebracht
und dort an der grenze zur slowakei ein
zufluchtsort von vielen hunderttausend
menschen schätzt das un
flüchtlingshilfswerk sind bereits
richtung westen geflohen standen oder
stehen noch immer schlange in endlosen
fahrzeugkolonne die letzten kilometer
gehen sie zu fuß frauen kinder die alles
zurücklassen müssen ihre väter ihre
männer die müssen kämpfen auch die
eltern von anastasia freunde brachten
sie eigentlich hierher ihr 13 jähriger
bruder ist noch immer in der ukraine
es war hart alles zurückzulassen mein
hund meine
eltern
kiew auch in dieser nacht wieder
gefechtslärm angriffe auf militäranlagen
und flughäfen putins militär behauptet
man ziele nicht auf zivilisten
heute morgen um kurz nach acht uhr traf
die wirklichkeit die angreifer lügen
eine russische rakete trifft ein
wohnhaus wieder tote wieder verletzte
mut macht der bürgermeister
uns war klar dass die nacht schwierig
werden würde denn die russen wollen ins
größtmöglichen schaden zufügen aber das
ist ihnen nicht gelungen
noch gelingt es den ukrainischen
soldaten offenbar die russen vor kiew
zurückzudrängen die verteidiger haben
sich ein die bevölkerung bekommt waffen
alle gegen putin der heute befiehlt die
angriffe auszuweiten
bilder des russischen fernsehens sollen
vom entschlossenen vordringen im osten
könnten wann und wo sie entstanden nicht
zu prüfen
tatsächlich scheint russland aus drei
richtungen weiter ins innere der ukraine
vorzudringen genaue frontlinien gibt es
nicht angeblich sei die stadt militär
pole im südosten der ukraine eingenommen
bilder im netz sollen den beschuss einer
klinik zeigen eine russische fahne über
dem eingang einer polizeistation
auch in anderen teilen des landes wie
hier in tschernitz soll dass
raketenangriffe auf wohnhäuser gegeben
haben ein kämpferischer präsident
spricht putins soldaten direkt an
je schneller sie ihre regierung sagen
dass der krieg sofort beendet werden
sollte desto mehr werden überleben
spielen sie die ukrainische nationalelf
zum trotz
während dem sport noch immer flüchtende
eintreffen
[Musik]
und wir gehen jetzt live nach kiew in
die nähe des präsidentenpalasts zu
meinem österreichischen kollegen
christian wehrschütz vom orf grüß gott
guten abend herr wer schutz wie können
sie uns die lage schildern wie sie sich
ihnen im moment bietet in kiel
wir haben in der nacht wieder flieger
erlagen gehabt diese erinnern waren in
der ganzen stadt zu hören aber die
unmittelbaren zentrum wo auch wir uns
befinden wir sind bringt praktisch mit
unserem büro nachbar des
präsidentenamtes haben wir zwar starke
sicherheitskräfte aber wir haben hier
direkt noch keine kämpfe wir haben uns
in unserer nähe natürlich auch eine u
bahn station die zu meiden hinunter
führt und dort haben wir natürlich eine
starke belegung von diesen plätzen
insgesamt gilt jetzt in kiew bereits
seit 17 uhr ortszeit das ist 16 uhr
unserer zeit eine ausgangssperre die bis
montag 8 uhr früh sieben jahre dauern
wird die bevölkerung wurde aufgefordert
sich mit lebensmitteln einzudecken zu
hause zu bleiben logischerweise
klitschko als bürgermeister von kiew hat
gesagt jeder der draußen ist wird das
feind angesehen es gibt es langsam
probleme im zentrum auch mit der
versorgung für brot haben wir heute
gesehen ist man zwei stunden angestanden
die meisten geschäfte im zentrum haben
zu und das ist natürlich eine sehr große
unsicherheit und angst da gekämpft wird
aber meistens noch er in außenbezirken
können sie haben sie einen überblick
darüber wo sich die meisten zivilisten
jetzt noch aufhalten sie sagten in der
metro zum beispiel aber das sind ja
nicht alle sind also auch noch sehr sehr
viele menschen in dieser millionenstadt
kiew einfach zu hause und wissen gar
nicht wie sie sich richtig schützen
sollen jetzt in dieser situation
genauso ist es kiew hat drei millionen
einwohner hatte drei millionen einwohner
wir haben heute gesehen dass es einen
starken zug zum zug gab also zur abfahrt
mit zügen raus aus der stadt wir hatten
ja unmittelbar nach beginn der kämpfe
enorme aufgeschlagen neun stunden zehn
stunden haben leute gebraucht um aus
kiefer raus zu kommen aber die masse der
bevölkerung ist sicher da man hat den
fernsehsendern gezeigt wie soll man sich
verhalten bei beschuss man soll sich in
die badewanne werfen das ist das
sicherste bereich man sollte auch noch
münster hineinlegen um vielleicht
schreibt mails abzufangen die stadt
gleich das sehen sie auch an hier den
bildern einer geisterstadt die leute
sind zu hause im luftschutzkeller oder
eben in der u-bahn aber die u-bahn ist
natürlich nur für sehr wenige geeignet
er wäre schon was erwarten sie von
dieser nacht kann man das in unterformen
sagen gibt es da warnungen meldungen
dass sie sich in irgendeiner form darauf
einrichten könnten was ihnen
möglicherweise bevorsteht
die deutschen behörden haben vor beginn
der kämpfe
ausgemacht dass unser büro in der roten
zone liegt dem personal beim präsidenten
link wir gehen dann möglicherweise
herunter in den luftschutzkeller den
sagt bei unserem hochhaus gibt aber ganz
generell muss man sich glaube ich auf
zwei dinge einstellen entweder die
russische seite wird mit massiven
angriffen vorgehen oder aber man schafft
die frage wie kann der krieg weiter
gehen denn heute ist es den russen nicht
gelungen wirklich weiter vorzurücken
also die verteidiger kiew sind auch in
vielen anderen landesteilen und wir
haben einen recht genauen überblick
halten sich sehr gut man schätzt die
zahl der toten russen auf 3000 es gibt
auch etwa 300 gefangene russische
soldaten bereits also entweder es wird
viel viel härter oder schauen wie kommt
eigentlich dann wladimir putin aus
seiner situation heraus borja den kampf
den krieg ins japanische länder tragen
muss sehr interessante informationen von
ihnen werden die nachher auch noch mal
mit einem militärstrategen einem
ehemaligen nato general genauer
versprechen für den moment ganz
herzlichen dank christian wehrschütz
meine österreichischer kollege vom orf
live aus kiew danke für diese
informationen und alles gute für sie der
schutz
dankeschön und dann müssen wir heute
abend dringend auch abseits der großen
städte ins weite land der ukraine gucken
da ist ein bedrückender track von
menschen unterwegs gen westen denn
sicherheit das heißt aktuell in
abertausenden fällen gern polen natalie
steger ist auf der polnischen seite
der grenze zur ukraine
natalie es gibt berichte über
erschütternde szenen bei ihnen von
stundenlangen wartezeiten können sie das
bitte mal ein bisschen beschreiben
also nix anmelden möchte beschreiben was
hier gerade passiert wir sind in coach
aber das ist eigentlich ein
autobahnübergang ein grenzübergang und
hier sind die menschen in den letzten
stunden sind sehr viele menschen sind zu
fuß in polen angekommen an diesem auto
bahnübergang und dann haben sich hier
lange schlangen auf polnischer seite
gebildet von autos von angehörigen die
diese menschen aufnehmen wollen aber
auch von unglaublich vielen freiwilligen
die helfen wollen die menschen irgendwie
weiter zu transportieren es gibt ja sehr
viele ukrainer in polen auch die
verwandte haben dass es hier gerade
passiert und jetzt versucht man die
menschen um das alles ein bisschen
geordnet dazu machen direkt in busse zu
bringen damit sie dann erstmal im warmen
sind und dann weiter gebracht werden zu
einem aufbau einkaufszentrum wurde an
die freiwilligen die helfen wollen und
auch die angehörige ihre angehörigen in
die arme schließen können haben wir
waren natürlich auch an dem
grenzübergang an dem man eigentlich zu
fuß drüber geht und dort gab es wirklich
erschütternde szenen also zum beispiel
ukraine die in polen arbeiten die
dringend darauf gewartet haben dass sie
endlich die kinder in die arme schließen
können und wir haben gehört dass auf der
ukrainischen seite an diesem grenzpunkt
bis zu 24 stunden die menschen zu fuß an
der grenze gewartet haben bei minus 34
grad vor allem kinder und frauen weil
die männer ja nicht raus dürfen und wenn
sie nach meinen eindrücken fragen den
letzten zwei tagen am anfang haben wir
wahnsinnig viele tränen gesehen und
mittlerweile wirken die menschen so
erschöpft viel zu erschöpft zum weinen
sogar zu schwach zum bei natalie
herzlichen dank für diese eindrücke von
der polnisch ukrainischen grenze
und jetzt nehmen wir die mitte auf die
straßen der ukraine zu denen die
versuchen sich zu verteidigen wir haben
es vorhin schon kurz gehört zu
verteidigen mit allem was sie haben zu
denen mit denen wladimir putin und seine
armee strategen möglicherweise so nicht
gerechnet haben diana zimmermann
felicity baker und lindsay hin zum
berichten
sie tun was sie können um den russischen
vormarsch aufzuhalten in der pro reifen
frauen und kinder am samstag styropor
stopfen es in bierflaschen
molotow-cocktails marke eigenbau auch
sie wollen helfen ihr land zu
verteidigen
neulich im leben vor der invasion bei
irina englischlehrerin
niemand dachte dass wir unser wochenende
so verbringen würden aber jetzt scheint
es euch das einzig wichtige wir können
unser normales leben nicht leben selbst
wenn wir jetzt noch sicher sind wir
müssen etwas tun
noch sind die russischen truppen nicht
jedoch die ganze stadt ein strategisch
wichtiger knotenpunkt ist in aktion
spenden werden gesammelt männer und
frauen melden sich freiwillig an die
waffe um gegen putin soldaten zu kämpfen
er dachte wirklich ich kann sich die
ukraine einfach so nehmen und in
russland verwandeln das ist nicht wahr
und es macht uns wirklich wütend
südlich von der pro heben freiwillige
gräben aus trainieren für den ernstfall
den sie unmittelbar erwarten ermutigt
von ihrem präsidenten der das land nicht
verlassen will
präsident biden hat unserem präsidenten
angeboten nach amerika zu gehen aber er
hat gesagt er bleibt bei uns wir fühlen
dass
der weg nach abo die cia führt am
wasserkraftwerk vorbei dass die sowjets
im zweiten weltkrieg zerstört haben um
den vormarsch der nazis zu stoppen wird
sich diese geschichte wiederholen
hinter der stadt ein checkpoint die
berichte von russischen verlusten lassen
die hoffnungen hier in den himmel
wachsen
nur der allmächtige weiß wann die russen
kommen denn sie werden geschlagen und
drehen sich im kreis sie kapieren dass
die ukraine von allen seiten auf sie
einschlägt
doch so groß die tapferkeit auch sein
mag lange werden sie die übermächtige
russische armee wohl kaum aufhalten
können
und zur militärischen lage ganz aktuell
bringen wir jetzt general egon ramms mit
in die sendung ehemals ranghöchster
deutscher nato befehlshaber general
guten abend
es gibt immer mehr meldungen dass die
invasion nicht ganz nach putins plan
läuft wir haben es gerade schon mehrfach
gehört aus ihrer sicht aus soldatischer
sicht welche anzeichen sehen sie dafür
dass es gibt eine menge meldungen und
hinweise darauf dass der vormarsch wir
müssen insbesondere vom norden her nicht
den geländegewinne erzielt hatte man
sich offensichtlich von russischer seite
her oft hat das auch am ersten tag des
krieges für die russen dort günstiger
aus die ukraine haben einen teil ihrer
kräfte umdisponiert und woanders hin
gebracht und so sich in den kräften die
von norden greifen in den weg gestellt
und das haben sie offensichtlich bisher
recht erfolgreich
kann man jetzt sagen dass wladimir putin
damit gerechnet hätte wirklich irgendwie
freudiger von der bevölkerung in der
ukraine empfangen zu werden oder wie
konnte es zu dieser möglichen
fehleinschätzungen kommen von russischer
seite aus also wenn man seine reden aus
dieser woche mal vergleicht seinen
aussagen mit dem was tatsächlich
passiert man hat ja offensichtlich
erwartet dass er mehr unterstützung
kriegen würde zumindest von den
russischen teil der bevölkerung und
sieht im augenblick so nach der
berichterstattung mit aller vorsicht aus
als wenn im prinzip die ganze keine
aufgestanden wäre um ihr vaterland und
ihre freiheit zu verteilen was heißt das
jetzt für putin ist zu befürchten dass
er jetzt sagt dann müssen wir noch
massiver noch härter noch verheerender
vorgehen davon müssen wir ausgehen es
gibt nach den einsatz grundsätzen der
russen den grundsatz beim angriff
gestaffelt vorzugehen ich gehe davon aus
dass wir jetzt was bisher in der ukraine
gesehen haben wir von der ersten staffel
reden können und es wird über kurz oder
lang wahrscheinlich relativ schnell die
zweite staffel eingeführt werden um ihr
sprechen raum gewinne zu erzielen und
damit seine strategischen ziele den
wildtieren zu nehmen um den präsidenten
zu entmachten zu erreichen und dann
müssen wir noch über eine entwicklung
reden die tatsächlich auch so sorgen
macht noch zusätzlich da geht es um
tschetschenische kämpfer die ja
berüchtigt sind wegen ihrer brutalität
jetzt hat der tschetschenische warlord
kdf manche sagen das ist quasi putins
mann fürs grobe
der hat jetzt gesagt sie seien auch
richtung ukraine unterwegs warum holt
putin sich verstärkung aus dieser
richtung
wir haben vorhin diese szene gesehen wo
zivilisten vor einem kampf verstanden
und offensichtlich die besatzung des
kampfpanzers nicht genau wusste wie sie
sich verhalten sollte über das ja im
prinzip bruder völker sind so rund um
solche situationen zu vermeiden ist dann
möglicherweise die tschetschenische
brutalität eine hilfe geboten
sagt der ehemalige nato befehlshaber und
deutsche general egon ramms ich danke
ihnen ganz herzlich heute abend für
diese analyse im heute-journal vielen
dank jörn herzlichen dank
ein geschichtslehrer der zum präsidenten
gewählt wird den spielte der komiker
wolodimir selensky in der populären
ukrainischen fernsehserie diener des
volkes
dann wurde er selbst zum präsidenten
gewählt das war kein schauspiel mehr das
war wahres leben belächelt wurde
selensky aber immer noch jetzt lacht
niemand mehr wolodimir selensky kämpft
um sein land sein amt und wohl auch um
sein leben er sei putins ziel nummer
eins sagt er und niemand würde
widersprechen
vergangene nacht versucht selensky mit
einem bemerkenswerten self video seinem
land mut zu machen und will gleichzeitig
die gerüchte kontern er sei längst nicht
mehr in kiew dara hassanzadeh guckt
hinter die kulissen
analog zur zeit erscheinen in den
sozialen netzen viele flicken übers dass
sich angeblich unsere armee aufrufe die
waffen niederzulegen und dass die
evakuierung angefangen hat also dazu ich
bin hier und wir legen die waffen nicht
ab russische propaganda widerlegt er mit
self wies präsident seelands gilt als
ziel nummer eins des russischen angriffs
und bleibt den kiew samt
sicherheitskabinett
collien abend allerseits der
fraktionsvorsitzende ist hier der leiter
des präsidialamtes ist hier der
premierminister hier wird der präsident
ist hier wir sind alle hier das militär
ist hier die bürger sind hier wir
verteidigen unsere unabhängigkeit unser
land das und das wird so bleiben
selenz gemacht mit seinem handy eine
neue frontlinie auf den kampf um die
russischsprachige zivilbevölkerung ein
tera dass präsident putin fremder nicht
sein könnte dieser demonstriert seine
macht in jedem öffentlichen auftritt
hält historische monologe für seine
bürger in denen er der ukraine das
existenzrecht abspricht
ihr völkermord im donbass vorwirft
ich weiß dass meine rede nicht im
russischen fernsehen übertragen wird
aber die bürger russlands lassen sie
sehen sie müssen die wahrheit erfahren
und die wahrheit ist das muss aufhören
bevor es zu spät
die russische regierung will nicht mit
uns über frieden reden
vielleicht will sie mit euch reden
wollen die russischen bürgerkrieg ich
würde die frage gerne beantworten
aber die antwort hängt von euch abdullah
ab was den bürgern russlands
gerade
nett wenn ihr keinen krieg dass fordern
einige hundert demonstranten heute in
jekaterinenburg
festnahmen folgen zwar auf dem fuß aber
seelands kiss hoffnung russlands
militärische übermacht durch die
russische zivilgesellschaft zu besiegen
sie lebt
wir haben gestern hier heute schon mal
gespannt in die vor uns liegenden acht
geschaut und da auf einen ehrwürdigen
saal in new york wo der
weltsicherheitsrat takt und es um krieg
und frieden ging und letztlich auch um
die glaubwürdigkeit dieses gremiums
jetzt ist die nacht vorbei und hanna du
hast das ergebnis dieser abstimmung im
blick ja und das war zum teil wie
erwartet die resolution gegen die
russischen angriffe auf die ukraine ist
gescheitert und zwar am veto russlands
allerdings china enthielt sich bei der
abstimmung genauso wie indien und die
vereinigten arabischen emirate die
restlichen elf staaten im un
sicherheitsrat stimmten für die
resolution
die diskussion um die einsatzfähigkeit
der bundeswehr geht weiter der
vorsitzende des bundeswehrverbands
wüstner fordert ein sofortprogramm die
politik müsse jetzt zitat endlich
aufwachen bei munition fahrzeugen
schiffen flugzeugen und ersatzteilen
gebe es massive probleme die vorsitzende
des verteidigungsausschusses strack
zimmermann forderte im tagesspiegel eine
deutliche erhöhung des
verteidigungshaushalts und auch
grünen-chefin lang zeigte sich offen für
höhere militärausgaben
vorrangig sei eine gute ausstattung der
soldatinnen und soldaten sagte lang der
funke mediengruppe
nicht nur in deutschland gingen heute
tausende menschen auf die straße um
gegen die russische invasion in der
ukraine zu protestieren weltweit gab es
friedens demonstrationen und
kundgebungen so zum beispiel in genf vor
dem hauptquartier der vereinten nationen
auch in paris und tokio versammelten
sich menschen und forderten ein ende des
krieges
[Musik]
so und dann können wir uns jetzt mal
gemeinsam den luftraum über europa
ansehen das hier ist ein denkwürdiges
bild der gesamte flugverkehr macht einen
großen bogen um die ukraine zu
gefährlich
überhaupt ist gerade speziell am himmel
zu sehen wie schnell verbindungen
gekappt werden verschiedene europäische
länder sperren ihren luftraum für
russische maschinen und damit quasi den
direkten weg aus russland gen westen
russland reagiert und verbietet mehreren
airlines das land anzufliegen und gerade
eben kommt die anmeldung dass auch die
lufthansa jetzt russland meidet es werde
jetzt zunächst keine flüge mehr nach
oder über russland von der lufthansa
geben und flüge die sich im russischen
luftraum befinden sagte ein sprecher
werden diesen in kürze wieder verlassen
europas sanktionen gegen putin und ihre
folgen christoph schneider gibt einen
überblick
[Musik]
sie sind in kraft neue sanktionen der eu
gegen russland jüngste maßnahme mehrere
östliche eu länder haben ihren luftraum
für russische flugzeuge gesperrt
die wegen russlands angriff auf die
ukraine erlassenen weiteren
strafmaßnahmen zielen darauf ab russland
und seiner wirtschaft deutlichen schaden
zuzufügen dafür werden beispielsweise
die
refinanzierungsmöglichkeiten des staates
und von ausgewählten russischen privaten
banken sowie weiterer unternehmen
eingeschränkt
und die eu erlässt auch
ausfuhrbeschränkungen für strategisch
wichtige güter die insbesondere
unternehmen aus dem energie und
verkehrssektor treffen sollen konkret
russlands zugang zu halbleitern und
anderen hightech produkten soll
erschwert werden die russische
luftverkehrsbranche soll von der
versorgung mit neuen flugzeugen
ersatzteilen und anderer technik
abgeschnitten werden russische
erdölraffinerien sollen künftig keine
ausrüstung und technologie bekommen die
für die modernisierung dort benötigt
werden sanktionen sollen auch die
staatliche russische
eisenbahngesellschaft rzd
den fahrzeughersteller cards und den
schiffbauer usc treffen
außerdem soll es verboten werden mehr
als 100.000 euro bei europäischen banken
anzulegen oder auf euro lautende
wertpapiere zu kaufen
darüber hinaus setzt die eu auch den
russischen präsidenten wladimir putin
und sein außenminister sergei lavrov
persönlich auf ihre sanktionsliste
damit können in der eu möglicherweise
vorhandene vermögen der beiden politiker
so eingefroren werden
und da ist da noch der europarat mit
sitz in straßburg 1949 gegründet hüter
von menschenrechten und demokratie
47 mitgliedstaaten gehören ihm an
darunter auch russland und die ukraine
wegen des bewaffneten angriffs auf die
ukraine wurde russland als teilnehmer
mit sofortiger wirkung suspendiert das
heißt es nehmen nun keine russischen
diplomaten und delegierten mehr am
wichtigsten gremium der europäischen
organisation teil russland bleibe aber
mitglied des europarats und der
europäischen menschenrechtskonvention
betonte das ministerkomitee des
europarats
ja und mitglied im parlament des
europarats ist die deutsche abgeordnete
jensen fdp sie wacht dort über die
einhaltung der
menschenrechtskonventionen vor jensen
schönen guten abend nach kiel genannt
tessiners der europarat suspendiert
russland wir habe es gerade gehört das
ist zuletzt 1969 passiert als die
griechische militär unter ausgeschlossen
wurde wer kann sich jetzt noch für die
menschenrechte in russland einsetzen
wenn sie die verbindungen kappen die
verbindung werden nicht gekappt das
haben wir auch im beitrag gehört es gibt
nach wie vor die möglichkeit für die
russische zivilbevölkerung auch vor dem
europäischen gerichtshof für
menschenrechte ihre anliegen
einzubringen und es gibt weiterhin auch
die möglichkeit sollten irgendwann
friedensgespräche anstehen auch über
dieses gremium nach wie vor
beratungen zu führen ich glaube deswegen
ist es umso wichtiger dass das zeichen
erfolgt ist aber wir lassen uns auch von
der russischen delegation nicht
verhöhnen und deswegen ist die
entscheidung richtig wurden sie auch von
der russischen delegation regelrecht
verwöhnt oder meinen sie jetzt allgemein
den angriff putins auf die ukraine man
muss ein bisschen zurück schauen wir
haben in der letzten legislatur des
europarates schon gesehen dass die
russische delegation regelrecht hohen
haft- und deswegen habe ich das wort
benutzt
delegierte in ihrer delegation entsandt
haben die auf europäischen
sanktionslisten standen so etwas ist
eine anmaßung gegenüber der wichtigen
aufgabe des europarates und deswegen
haben wir damals schon in frage gestellt
ob es richtig ist die russische
delegation aufzunehmen bzw wieder dabei
zu haben und deswegen befürworte ich
sehr dass jetzt ausgeschlossen und
suspendiert wurden so jetzt geht das
ganze allerdings nochmal deutlichen
schritt weiter von ihrer seite aus
natürlich aber eben auch von der
russischen seite wir haben heute den
stellvertretenden vorsitzenden des
russischen nationalen sicherheitsrats
gehört den früheren präsidenten medwedew
der droht dem westen mit einem komplett
abbruch der diplomatischen beziehungen
und er sagt über den europarat ihre
entscheidung sei unfair und zitat der
grund ein grund die tür zu dieser
organisation endgültig zuzuschlagen
macht ihnen das sorgen nein das macht
mir keine sorgen der spielball für die
aufnahme von jeglicher art von
kommunikation der liegt aus meiner sicht
bei wladimir putin das sieht man wenn er
seinen sicherheitsstab regelrecht
abkanzelt dass wenn es überhaupt
gesprächskanäle in an die zu diesem
zeitpunkt wo putin europa angreifen
putin die ukraine angreift geben soll
dann müssen die von putin erfolgen aber
derzeit nicht erfolgt werden herr
medwedew sagt eben auch wir haben jetzt
die möglichkeit in russland zum beispiel
die todesstrafe wieder einzuführen da
haben sie dann jetzt also tatsächlich
noch weniger einfluss in russland direkt
nach dieser entscheidung als ohnehin
schon vorher diese gesprächskanäle die
bestehen ja auch über eine
parlamentarische versammlung des
europarates hinaus die zivilgesellschaft
in russland die geht gerade auf die
straße trotzdem sie mögliche auch
physische strafen fürchten muss ich
glaube an diese an diesem punkt muss man
betonen dass putin nicht russland ist
aber der spiel bei bei präsident putin
liegt und die zivilgesellschaft auch von
uns auf anderen wegen gestärkt werden
muss und kann okay da habe ich noch eine
ganz aktuelle frage wo heute abend für
sie sie waren vorsitzende des bundestags
menschenrechtsausschusses
unterstützen sie jetzt die deutschen
waffenlieferungen an die ukraine ich
befürworte das ist jetzt zu dieser
entscheidung gekommen ist und wie
kanzler scholz ja auch richtig sagt das
ist eine zeitenwende und die zeit
erfordert genau diese voraussetzungen
dass wir uns auch an die seite von einem
demokratischen einem souveränen staates
stellen denn am ende geht es darum in
europa freiheit menschenrechte
demokratie zu verteidigen und
menschenrechtsschutz ist dann nicht per
se das was wir auch ohne den beistand
tun können und am ende ist es eine
verteidigung eine selbstverteidigung und
bei der möchten wir unterstützen und ich
halte das für die genau richtige
entscheidung aus dem parlament des
europarats die deutsche abgeordnete
guido jansen fdp ich danke ihnen in den
norden vielen dank danke
liebe zuschauerinnen und zuschauer wenn
sie den menschen in der ukraine helfen
wollen dann können sie das nach wie vor
tun beim aktionsbündnis
katastrophenhilfe das stichwort ist zdf
nothilfe ukraine hier ist die bahn de 65
100 106 100 104 106 100 und all das kann
man auch noch mal im internet oder im
zdf text nachlesen und wir haben jetzt
hier noch einmal nachrichten mit diana
in hamburg schleswig-holstein und dem
saarland sind heute die impfungen mit
nova wachs gestartet der neue impfstoff
ist protein basiert er funktioniert also
anders als die mrm stoffe die hoffnung
ist dass dies auch bisherige im
skeptiker überzeugen kann in den meisten
anderen bundesländern sollen die novaks
impfungen in der kommenden woche
beginnen viele noch die lottozahlen von
diesem samstag die lauten 6 16 33 43 45
49 und die superzahl 7 alle angaben wie
immer ohne gewähr
das wetter in der nächsten woche wird
überwiegend freundlich hier die
aussichten morgen ist es im osten und
südosten teils länger bewölkt sonst nach
auflösung örtlicher nebelfelder viel
sonne höchstwerte vier bis elf grad in
den nächsten tagen wird es oft sonnig
nur am dienstag im nordwesten etwas
regen nachts wird es frostig kalt
tagsüber höchstwerte von vier bis zwölf
grad
vladimir jurowski ist dirigent er ist
künstlerischer leiter des rundfunk
sinfonieorchesters berlin
und er ist russe heute abend vor knapp
zwei stunden ist sein orchester im
berliner konzerthaus aufgetreten mit
einem veränderten programm die
symphonische ouvertüre nummer eins von
wickies wird jetzt gespielt und vom
selben komponisten die nationalhymne der
ukraine
im text dazu heißt es leib und seele
geben wir für unsere freiheit
eine ganze reihe von prominenten aus der
kulturwelt in russland hat jetzt seine
erklärung veröffentlicht der von
russland begonnene krieg ist eine
schande heißt es dort das ist unsere
schande
und das war das heute journal an diesem
samstag danke dass sie mit uns dabei
waren und die nächsten nachrichten mit
allen weiteren entwicklungen im ukraine
krieg gibt es um 00 40 in der heute
express bis morgen wenn sie mögen ihnen
allen
[Musik]